[Music]  I guess I'm gonna sit back with Craig  Mac the rapper who had the first hit on  Diddy's iconic hip-hop label Bad Boy  Records died on Monday  Colton County coroner's office confirms  to ET that the musician died at his home  in Walterboro South Carolina around 9:00  p.m. Monday night of what appeared to be  natural causes the hip-hop artist who  was born in Queens New York is perhaps  best known for his 1994 hit song flava  in your ear which sold over a million  copies and was nominated for a Grammy  it was later remixed by notorious b.i.g  LL Cool J Busta Rhymes and rampage  [Music]  Mack released his first album project  funked a world with Diddy but later left  the label and came out with his second  record operation get down in 1997  [Music]  following his successful rap career in  the 90s Mack left the music industry  reportedly to pursue his religion Street  by those two my wife and even just one  person I'm responsible for that one  first about that perfect  [Music]